it's good to have any man listen for
anyone who doesn't know you
let's just quickly get the whole thing
out of the way you're known for the Nazi
pub video which you made for YouTube
which went viral you had a court case or
resulted from that tell us very quickly
about that for anyone doesn't know I
made a joke and Gomez did essentially my
girlfriend was constantly going on about
her cute adorable hot pug was she
wouldn't sharp about that I thought it
would be funny to teach the dog to do
horrific things like Nazi salute and
react to the phrase gasps the Jews and I
made up a do-over
it went online it went viral I got
arrested I went for a two-year trial
which lasted mmm twice as long as the
Nuremberg trials and ultimately I was
thrown go here and there famed eight
hundred pounds which I've refused to pay
and so no it was just a case of waiting
for the cops to come and get me well
obviously this wasn't in the UK you were
live in North Korea at the time no no
this was a and the United People's
Republic of Scotland right and where are
you with it now because you've had a
bunch of Appeals and and stuff like that
I ended up I went through tried to go
through the actual regular appeal
process and the way it works is those
like are seft
process it's basically to stop people
from there wasting the appeals courts
time for example a man could walk into
the police station with his decapitated
waist head in his hand with a USB stick
containing the video of him doing it and
then he would go I won't help you I was
a system set up to prevent people like
that from wasting their people courts
time and what happens is at the frost
stage one judge reviews it and it was
basically a huge a fuse but fuse before
wheels thing where he basically told me
I was lucky I doesn't go to jail and he
even threatened my lawyer of contempt of
court for doing his job and they ended
up over the second time after that we
appealed again the second set it get
rejected
we then dead something called normally a
[ __ ] you which is where you have people
to the highest judge and a judge in the
land going can you please hear me out
because I'm getting [ __ ] up here when
they went in front of the highest judge
in the land who and no
just sent us on our way so that was a
very expensive nor and no the only thing
we've really got left is the Scottish
criminal case review commission which
can take months and I could get packed
up at any time and do my time in jail
before that they even process or
submissions or yeah sure pretty sure
yeah so how long could you do in jail
essentially um and more importantly this
is a thing that blew my mind what did
you get charged with Elmo's section
section 1 2 7 their Communications Act
the 2003 posting a ffensive message or
offensive content on a social media
platform so it was I was literally
convicted over cos and gross offence
something which is a completely
subjective and also you know they've
kind of a replaced my intent and remove
the context of why I dead in order to
secure that conviction because here's
the thing that worries me is who gets to
judge what is offensive like I'm a West
Ham fan I find their back forward times
grossly offensive you know infuriating
and but who's to say who makes that
judgment the Scottish courts that's what
the prosecution of the Crone said he
says that people don't get to decide
what they fail defense of the court gets
to decide what as an as an offensive I
am not joking he literally said
[Music]